so uh go slow today cuz it's your first
time that yes sir all right so uh this
is a stop hit strategy so the guy's
coming at you right when he comes at you
you're going to uh project him back then
draw from
concealment so don't do it hard just
work on the mechanics so we're kind of
close he's walking aggressively you
don't want that
okay so right as soon as he does it boom
up into his throat so I'm hitting here
and it keeps going up into his throat
and you have to ground of course cuz
otherwise he bounces you bounce off of
him okay so he
moves draw back get off the line notice
how I come around okay yes sir we're
only going to take a couple steps so
it's fine if we have a little backwards
you
go off the line
aw okay let's
try so we'll do the same stop pitch boom
in and we're going to draw our knife on
this one
okay so same
thing all your knife
the dra the
knife KNE okay here we go okay uh this
time he makes like a a kind of grab for
you okay go ahead yeah that's what he's
doing
okay uh we're going to whatever hand he
grabs with you always want to go to the
outside okay we'll go to the outside so
he goes to the outside and I'll kick in
that groin I'll circle around do my drop
okay that again
okay let's try all right in this one he
makes some sort of grab ATT I don't okay
and you're going to get off the line
make your connection generate your
Ki you get your distance and then drw
don't don't look don't get
preoccupied he goes and you're like
you're going to drw and thr him just
project get out of the way that's
it get your distance
okay let I'll do like a two-handed high
grab so he's trying to grab grab me
somewhere
okay just like before you're going to
make contact okay and you will if you
can you make him go around
you but if he's really strong on one
side he past me okay the goal of this is
to either make him go around me or go
underneath to the outside of here okay
do the same
thing we want to get to the outside we
don't want to be in here wrestling with
this guy and then try to do this stuff
okay we save that for a guy who's
turning trying to catch up so boom I can
project on the outside cool
on the inside
are or one side and on the
outside okay let's try what you know if
you're interested in
self-defense what kind of stuff do you
carry okay so I have my handgun I have a
spare magazine this is magazine
malfunctions or my problem is bigger
than one mag okay you have a handheld
flashlight on one side
on the handgun you have a tack
light on the other side to support your
handgun you have a quick drawing knife
okay in our state fixed blades are not
uh legal but if you were in another
state you that would be a fixed blade it
would be on your
support then you have some stop the
bleeding so tourit and glove
you'll have your
ID you have to have your ID this
hits the fan and then just on this side
I carry my my keys and but they're in a
kind of if that's all I have it'll work
okay and so that's just you every day no
one knows okay can't really see it or
anything all right